it all started in the spring of 2016
that Jasper newspapers was the
announcement a collage of a group of
tourists in the National Park the police
report it was just an accident
because the band what's the raft on the
river but you sure that but you sure
that they're definitely implicated one
of the most elusive creatures known as
Bigfoot or Sasquatch you and your team
of researchers decide to get to the
truth mm-hmm well we sure which we very
sure definitely sure yep oh you copied
me are we both the chick haha we criminy
the mouth sensitivity in this game is
nauseating oh yeah I don't know maybe
you can turn that down no you can't no
lilten appear that you can't when you
walk the bobbing is like oh yeah so uh
welcome to this not [ __ ] game it's quite
well made hope you know so which part of
America does this take place in part
yeah in like the Sequoia area like I
know where that is
yeah I was hoping you would all right
then so what you got to do see that gun
above the map over here
no oh right here oh okay yeah take rifle
take that rifle you take that one take
one box of these bullets over there on
the shelf
ah bullets and munition you can actually
take two
go ahead and take two I'll give you more
ammo all right I know what a crack shot
you are all right take some care of it
when I spin around like crazy you have
no idea how good of a shot I am is it
one battery per camera or two bucks no
no the the batteries are for night
vision so take you can hold four so take
four got it I'll take four
I'll get the a Murrow you see in this
fridge there's meat take three ah meats
is mad
this isn't organized this is a this is
not cooked meat no it is not Bigfoot
thanks for
oh okay yeah we don't need meat Bigfoot
needs meat okay move into that room I
can i I cannot pass through you look at
the realistic physics take some traps
take three
where the like I need to turn that off
without touching it if it directly
connected to your cerebellum the kinetic
link exactly okay so if you right-click
at the slightest hesitation you're gonna
you're gonna turn on night vision or I
can't go up no no I didn't pick up a
battery that's why urine you're gonna
get a battery
guard hey guard how's it gone
we heard that actually looks pretty good
yeah - oh man you're really working it
out of that Oh
we're gonna get Bigfoot we're gonna all
do it yeah do it I'm gonna Bigfoot yeah
okay that's not the perfect way to start
this video not a good that's not how
this is that other point of this game ah
you know I don't know maybe this our
Bigfoot cage maybe Bigfoot hired us in
some sort of BDSM fashion but I'm gonna
assume know what happens if I shoot you
uh probably gonna kill me so reload you
get a press R to get it loaded I'm Way
ahead of you I'm Way ahead of you okay
so these are tracking bullets if you
hold down cue you'll notice hmm we
actually have a map this time which is
good you know oh you only need one shot
so pretty much I'll focus on tracking
them first because the tracker lasts for
a few minutes before you have to track
them again if you come over here we all
right all right I'm going to show you
how to lay down a trap you take AI you
press GE you push T yeah but there's
more to it than that it's complicated
for some [ __ ] reason so you lay down
a trap point you rip a branch here by
pressing Y on a tree boom and then you
press V on your trapped flop down there
the leaves there do you see how no one
would ever be able to figure this out in
their goddamn life yeah what the hell
yeah then you take your meat and yep
push Eon the nevermind I took the trap
that was dumb of me he's activated early
that's not that's
that's not right wait now if you gotta
like come after us
ah maybe okay hang on we wait for da
know we're probably I don't know that's
way early for him to be coming out of
the woodwork like that so I got a trap
here so that's how we set traps you
don't always need to meet them but it's
good to have one needed if I walk into
it yeah it will hurt you that yeah real
bad yeah
after that we just need to find Bigfoot
oh cool cool right get him to walk into
that one trap that I already forgot
where it is there's a little gray symbol
up in the air you can see it's very well
camouflaged dude where you see right up
here you see in the in the air oh my god
it's [ __ ] invisible I know the
transparent white symbol on a mostly
white background impossible I know all
right well whatever well we should put
some cameras up or something yeah yeah
so if you hold down cue wherever you put
cameras it'll show a little number
because there when you put it down it's
able to be read back in the van and it's
coordinated by the number that it is so
when they do that you've got your very
[ __ ] and then you make the cameras
and then you can watch around the place
and then hopefully not get mauled to
death by a Bigfoot how does that help
anybody if it's pointed directly at dog
looks in the direction that I'm oh yeah
done help no but I thought I thought it
was like rake rolls I thought you like
stuck into the tree yeah I want to set
up an impenetrable camera fortress uh I
hate to break it to you but these
cameras swivel when you're looking okay
you know what now you don't have to swim
all right but what the [ __ ] [ __ ] on
my party yeah I do
your call said mister I'm trying to help
you twin sister happy mister sister yeah
don't call me that
yes sir I told you not to call me that
yeah you're such a dead look in your
eyes right now you're just like ah so do
you just talking hate being stuck here
with this Dutch I can't believe we're
out in the woods together
Stacey watch out for big
but he lurks around every single corner
that you stand upon so no big feet
though right so you should be like I can
like here I'm coming no that's the thing
you think that but that's not true
weird blowing your mind running camera
right there that's fine we're good
you press Q what good are we doing with
these cameras right by our base where
we're going to be at I don't know I
thought they were like security cameras
yeah they are but maybe we're on a
master Bigfoot hunter you [ __ ] leave
then how about trying to if you're late
what no well maybe that's where Bigfoot
called from so maybe he's over there
that's kind of what I was going for all
right fine you really just want to get
into a fight to the death with this
[ __ ]
all right so I better get feet really
are about that fight to the death
it's probably going to happen definitely
and you're not gonna you're not gonna
like it too much when it does happen
because he's going to kill you dead and
you're gonna die yeah it'll be fun hey
wait this is a good this is a good tree
I like this tree line here you could
probably lay some traps along this tree
and if you chases us then you know maybe
we had a chance there I could already
have one nice an exit right on there or
no me no you can pay this you made one
of them and then maybe he'll hit both of
them okay hey good like a dumb piece of
[ __ ] now we just gotta hope that he
comes across this way sick burn put the
camera down right we'll just stand like
right here in between these you just
stepped on the goddamn trap you idiot
so I can just stay off myself well
that's not hard
well you goddamn right well I'll go
ahead and I'll go ahead and reset your
trap since he messed that one up
oh thank ya I messed that one up thank
you very much Stacey it's always you
that's mess everything up just like you
messed up our parents marriage I went
that doesn't even make sense I'm running
I'm trying if they're still married I'm
trying to imply that they're going to be
divorced because you work grownups
Jessica yeah I'll do that before I'm
sorry you know you don't like to be
called Jessica Bernice Bernice how could
you
I'm coming from that name you know what
it means because it's a sick Bernice
well your name Stacy yes my mom has got
it goin on a lot a lot velocity friend
can I shoot a tracking dart into you and
then track you I'm sure you could but
please don't Susie hey Dee you see my
player uh-uh
I see the reflection of it on my gun but
I don't actually see a flare look up
it's just trees man I mean look up oMG
I'm so alone here help me please coming
I'm coming towards you
anybody oh there you are hi hi of my
magical Kinetoscope it's pretty good too
bad we were cursed about maybe nine
times so is that gonna be cool ya know
it's probably not gonna be cool we
should probably make our way back to the
camp and I'm gonna put another dressed
and I'll just stand out here in the open
oh you know we were hanging about this
area why are you trapping over here so
much I don't know I just like it I don't
know it literally he comes from any
direction that he feels like you you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] know something no no
I don't know nothing I never played this
game before man [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
cheating [ __ ] well how is it
cheating if I'm helping us together as a
team
eating help us as a team yeah I mean
that might be what I'm doing whoa Adam
what's up what's up what's up oh he's
running he's running what a big baby
can't wait I'm nailing him now I miss
him okay so if you hold down cue now
we've got a little dot where he is so do
we like chase him down and kill him er
no no he's coming back Louise come back
I'm gonna try to get him to chase me and
then I'm gonna lead him into the traps
he's going far so he's just starting to
come back oh yeah going into the swamps
yeah he usually comes up for one hit and
then he takes off like a little [ __ ]
baby
please come back if he sees either one
of us just start shooting oh god he's
here he's here where is he he's were
close what does that dot mean ah
he's other areas he tell me his
company's gonna be kept for me he came
from me trying to leave him good address
not this way Bob oh he hit me i'ma die
okay wait that means he's moving right
where are you
where'd he go wait I see blood where the
heck did he go he's still tracked he's
not gonna track during all those so I'm
gonna need to need to chase him down and
then track him again okay he seems to be
going towards camera two now which might
not York's camera - yeah raps they're
right yeah there's their straps are so
stay away from there like a good bit of
way shit's not tracked anymore don't
worry we know where he's going
we just got stay away from there you
keep the tracking bullet on there we're
gonna tag him as soon as he hits those
traps we just need to stay a good
distance away to get trapped for a while
in those things maybe you just took
damage yeah you just got hit by all
right comin comin comin comin comin
comin comin comin spring clean amber -
yeah these are right around this rock
where ya buddy where you at buddy here
I'm Way any track you gotta have a trap
we didn't get there example you hit him
no I'm way far away oh no oh no oh no I
see him oh no I see you I see the blood
[ __ ]
Lawson [ __ ] I don't the cracker off for
that knots okay it's all right dude you
we can get him again wait these trap but
he got active these traps are fine what
did he take damage from I don't know oh
no this was triggered the dragon so we
got the meat out of that one okay so I'm
gonna replace meat on this one see ya
the that one trap hit did about as much
damage as we did with all of our guns
he's going to come back for one of these
meats so keep your tracker on I'm gonna
go over to the other traps okay and then
hopefully he's not gonna kill us
yeah we'll see about that actually we
can just Aggie you don't need to be over
there we can just watch with the camera
because that's what the cameras are for
watching your traps plus I can come
inside you go inside and close the door
can he not [ __ ] with us
not really I mean it's all you stay in
the door but I can't lose now yeah
I'm gonna take a nap alright well you
could open the window yeah that doesn't
seem like you guys we want I've got my
eyes on the camera you taken a good nap
there
a tactical nap had just reclose the
window so you're welcome good job good
tactical clone then I open this one and
then I closed it okay
all right no we're fine really yeah I
think so
I'm doing important stuff out here
basically it's what I'm saying I can see
that you masturbating
note in the camper I'm watching the
other traps ah brightly right okay sorry
I'm gonna go out there I'm gonna place a
camera what if we came back and he was
just like on the computer watching porn
I mean yes I couldn't blame him not many
Bigfoot ladies the biggest effete he's
just watching porn on the site that's
called like big titty big feet Bernice I
told you we were never gonna catch
Bigfoot Stacey why don't you ever
believe me you saw him we can catch him
yeah I saw him and we shot him and
[ __ ] radioactive blood came out of
him and then he ran away yeah well whose
job was it to hit him with the tracker
sounds like your kind of job no we said
we agreed it was you but like a you
thing oh god he's here
I tracked him I'll help I'll direct him
ah turn man wait I had the wrong bolt in
[ __ ] sorry miss ah Jesus
I think I saw James yeah a rock oh Jesus
Lord James right well he's taken off god
dammit how did he sneak up on us I don't
know he was literally like 30 feet away
from me and then he just growled and it
was like oh well he's crossing a bridge
come on do it yeah no no not the bridge
come back [ __ ] come back how
[ __ ] big is this place god it's
[ __ ] huge well he turned her out yeah
yeah he turned around yeah he come back
coming coming coming coming
ah oh no he's not coming for me oh my
god he's coming for me ow
oh [ __ ] out up the bridge coming towards
the bridge along the river line right
now oh [ __ ] okay okay he's he's onto me
I think he suspects something
damn it he's running away monday sighs
now
oh god damn it we're gonna be [ __ ]
impossible oh we saw Jesus he's all I
see him on the other side of the lake
god this [ __ ] he's never been like
this before like every time I played
this game he's always been like beeline
for me over and over again we might not
be able to catch Bigfoot we like run out
of time or anything here no no you run
out of bullets though and then they just
sort of [ __ ]
uh-huh I've got one piece of meat and
maybe if we kill deer we can get more
meat there are deer in this in these
woods
let's just go face this [ __ ]
down whatever yeah what else you got
shots we run up bullets just beat him
with your hands all right tough can it
be well the only problem is he keeps
running to the opposite side of the
world so I don't know how good that's
going to do us how big can his feet be
that's what I'm saying um it's in his
name you don't have a name like that if
you got tiny feet unless you're like
Little John and you're actually [ __ ]
running away from me kinda Here I am on
the other side of the lake right now
following his ass alright I'm going to
close in from the other direction
tracker just went away
but we know where he is I'm gonna I got
one tracker left let's take my gun up
your ass and then make you pull the
trigger with your own foot that's nice
oh that hammer oh dear I see him I see
him I see him
yeah um starting heading for like the
furthest north east point the [ __ ]
could possibly get to you obviously
obviously of course why because why now
I see him wait he's running he's running
for you or running away from you he's
not running toward me what's directions
he going did I get him
[ __ ] I totally hit him with that
tracker the [ __ ] is oh no I did get him
I did get him ok he's just going you see
him on the map oh good ok I must have
been chasing a deer that last time I'm
here to kill you piece of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you or whatever Apes [ __ ] big
big-footed freak freaking freak you're
[ __ ] free what do you think you are
having feet that big embarrassing all of
us you should be rendering me no not
that way not that way not that way no
not that way no god dammit
see ha ha ha ha
unloading ah so annoying
goddamnit [ __ ] you Bigfoot survival
Bigfoot it you know what let's just go
on a camping trip how about that you
know what maybe we should identify our
problems as siblings and just work
through them maybe we don't need Bigfoot
to fix us that's almost definitely true
I'll so I'm right behind you I don't
know if you've seen me oh no I have not
oh hey hi hi look hey Vito
[Laughter]
[Music]